as some of you know the current
tournament going on right now is the
chest candidates and last week I did a
game of tope tope law of the only other
player in the field who has been a world
champion and who was playing like he's a
champion is you know Viswanathan Anand
from India
five-time world champion and he's
playing really well I've often counted
him out in recent tournaments and he's
proving me wrong so I decided I would
cover one of his games kramnik and top
love sorry
Anand in table one one common feature
between both those players is they both
became world champions after Kasparov
retired and that's a big thing to kind
of note because bar I've had you know
pretty good scores against both of them
and it did open up the the field a bit
it was a very highly competitive field
afterwards there's no necessarily clear
number one when Kasparov retired and I'm
gonna look at Game five of their match
in 2008 prime mix white Ananda's Bach I
believe it was in Germany the match and
at this point I think I got bye-bye
game 5 is up 1 1 win in the match so he
was leading d4 d5 c4 c6 they're playing
a lot of Slavs this tournament or this
match as you know it's chess fashion it
depends on the time but often you'll see
the same opening over and over and then
they'll stop playing it the next year so
at this time this was the this was quite
popular and crime Nick of course is
mainly a d4 player of these days but one
of the best theoretically u6 III so
these are all made moves and like you
know this could be turn into the Marin
but yeah this is all theory that's been
going on for a long time
and at this point after Knight B to d7
blacks moves are normal white has a few
different options here Queen c2 Bishop
d3 b3 they all have some some you know
benefits
it depends depends on your taste and in
this match and in this game kramnik was
giving preference to Bishop d3 Queen c2
the benefit of that is you know black
you see delays taking on c4 after Bishop
d3 it's pretty immediate black takes
because whites are just spent a move
developing a bishop so you take on c4
you wait for them to develop division to
take on c4
after Bishop c4 c5 Bishop d3 a6 so one
of the main main main line main lines
here
there's also Bishop d7 but yeah they
were they were going into this quite a
bit this is just still the opening phase
in their preparation 86 you want to play
c5 next move simple as that you just
want to play c5 and not have b5 hanging
that's the opening I've never played too
much but back yeah back then back then I
think both crammed againand and then
we're playing this opening is black so
they're both very well-versed here
that's it and the most principled line
for white here is e for black played a
six white immediately takes action in
the center and now
okay this at one point this was a scary
move for for black bears to deal with
but now modern theories see five anyways
after E 5 the other move would be D 5
it's still still being played these days
C 4 and in this line yeah this line is
so some people yeah some people you can
go for this it's gonna be a little bit
different black why usually takes on e6
black plays moves like you know I think
Queen c7 and 95 it's double edged it's
double edge but but a couple players
still plays I'll say it's falling out of
fashion for the most part but there's a
couple Thursday play e5 which is what
comic roses deal is the only other real
continuation you would not want to you
know take and allow 95 you just know you
play EE for to play e5 right away now if
white if black had to play something
like 95 9 takes d5 I think Vaughn g5 and
probably just cancelling this is not not
to set up for block block you want stuff
Bishop to have a nice diagonal here here
you can't even like castle you have to
watch out for 95 ideas it would not be
the way to go C takes d4
and and this line now Knight takes p5
you can take here but after D takes c3
let's say F g7 Bishop g7 black is doing
very well here in 95 is coming just
ahead and development and up upon upon
takes an 8x p5 eight takes p5 now I
remember this this game I was watching I
that was about 16 at the time and a
feeling master so this was the first
World Championship match I had watched
where I was I'd say a decent chess
player two years previous when they had
the last one I was like 1800 so at least
when I was a feed a master I could
understand a little bit more of what was
going on so I was following this match
this was the first match I actually
followed a bit carefully and this one
reason why I picked this game is I think
it was my favourite game during the
match I do remember watching it I got in
trouble at school for for having a tab
with the chess games hidden but I would
bring it up whenever the teacher would
move away in computer class but I got
caught a few times and they're like you
know you can't play games during class
I'm like I'm not playing games this is
chess and I'm even just watching but
couldn't really explain to the teacher
what what I was doing so I got in
trouble a few times during that match
but it was it was it was the first one I
got into but yeah this is an old line
you got that's like bogoljub of Bodmin
bloody neck they're all playing playing
this so this the theories theory here is
is quite developed and one so this
White's going to Castle black has you
know bit worse King position but some
tactical you know counter player Queen
b6 but should be seven it's rook c8
it's it's a sharp line and you know
that's the it was nice in that sense
that you know the
we were right now we're not maybe seeing
as many games go into like some position
like this that that's so sharp and that
they're just playing a position here
you know whites down a pond with lots of
compensation he's probably gonna get it
back actually but like there aren't too
many games these days played at the top
level that will resemble the this type
of position or variation we'll get into
a couple moves later and it's it's it's
pretty exciting there's a lot of a lot
of possibilities so after castling clean
b6 is a move is a move remember you
can't take on b5 because it's going a5
check and well that takes here trying to
remember what what happens after night
Knight takes d4 usually an issue with
this type of home
95 Bishop b5 check
black might just actually be giving up
the the next one is well hi I will I
will not say something off here I'll
just say yeah there's there's something
something wrong with Nate xt4 here I'm
pretty sure it's Queen b6 and for
example here okay first of all you're
not gonna probably play move like 95
because after like this should be seven
castles rook gg8 okay this is the type
of compensation or this is why the
opening is really dangerous
so you know I mean Queen Queen b6 maybe
Bishop b5 here I mean I don't know they
should be for track yeah I think you
know it's very concrete but black is
getting a lot of compensation after
Knight takes d4 Queen b6 I think there's
just a button a lot of a lot of
compensation it's coming anyways I don't
think White's supposed to take on b5 so
why why white wants to be down upon with
that activity for now so anyways this is
this 90 x d4 would be possible but
there's a reason they didn't go for it
so now castles
and Queen b6 Queen yeah Queen just goes
to b6 it doesn't get hit on the C file
bishops always going to be seven it
helps that and you know the Knights on D
7 so now it takes d4 is not possible
with some sort of discovered Bishop b5
check Queen to Bishop h6 what would
white be playing I think just to direct
a four here you know if you played
before probably even a five clean-ass to
move off of it and then d4 will probably
hang plus blacks just I mean losing some
time just a four you know the
compensation for whites development is
apparent here so you can't be too greedy
and I think Anand was going for for
Bishop e7 which is what he played for
activity and just a really sharp middle
game also there's those moves like I'm
not even sure move like rook b8 a4 could
be played as well but I don't even moves
like Bishop f4 probably you don't want
to give block really enjoys the
structure up 66 it covers all the center
squares if you have to make play some
move like this it's it's a bit more
double-edged but now all the light
squares are a week and you know castling
is not no longer an option there there's
it's it's not a move you you want to
make so yeah after after Bishop a6 a4 is
pretty pretty annoying
yeah you found some of you don't want to
make sure you five we can f5 now the
Queen and Bishop can line up on it's
just the pawns are no longer flexible
its and here in this case not really
even threatening to take but yeah I just
it's I would just think it's a little a
little too too loosening see because in
a position like this or we'll see what
happens in the game blocks King gets
stuck in the center but it's really hard
to break the formation of e-cigs I've
Sixth once you put something on on you
five their sacrifices but there's also
ideas like Knight h4 and Knight f5
there's some annoying I don't know for
me I just don't like yeah II want to
play Bishop b7 and after Bishop takes b5
rook g8 definitely a position still in
preparation I think they're game to the
during this match the game beforehand
was also the same variation are very
similar so one thing that I was like I
liked when I was following the game is
you know watching online play dynamic
chess is is always a treat so this
position block has open lines you know
there's good bishops White has two
connected passed pawns on the Queen side
it's it's very sharp it's very sharp as
black as black you know when you when
you're looking at this you have more
Center pawns you got a good rook there
it's it's like you probably want to keep
some pieces in the board on the board
you don't want to go to four for pure
endgame because white has you know to to
pass pawns on the Queen side but
otherwise otherwise yeah probably you
know Bishop d6 King e7 you want to use
the pressure against the g2 to create
something
on the flip side if you do trade off
some pieces those Center puns
you can push right now I was like yeah
it's a little bit risky too pushy five
or things like that is more peaceful on
the board the King position might matter
more so it's a it's it's it's hard to
make some some decisions in this
position but in the meantime no matter
what black has to improve pieces rook
create the rook has to go to G black is
not planning the castle not Bishop long
b5 is ping the night route g8 it's the
only it's a natural square for the room
so the both players still have to go
through a couple normal development
thing moves before they really let me
figure out what they want to do but in
the previous game in the event on end by
Bishop d6 here so Ricci it was the
novelty at the time Bishop f4 as
expected maybe
and now Bishop d6 I think a lot of
people might prefer White's position
here because I mean what tax attack
doesn't like fully work you just always
have to worry about that Center like for
example here chronic plays Bishop g3
because he wants to you wants to turn
off the bishops but under White's
conditions because the G foul is
annoying it is annoying
for example Bishop Bishop d6 Queen d6
rook aft one if you have to always deal
worry about g2 then you know probably
black and play this move or or maybe now
you five but g2 g2 is a very annoying
annoying possibility here you know then
you're there's always this Bishop takes
f3 so the benefit of after Bishop d6
Bishop g3 is if block takes on g3 it
like this those tactics don't work
anymore that G file is shut down so
Bishop f4 Bishop to d6 another move
which I think attention has to be paid
is like a move like rook t1 you know
Bishop f3 is never possible to try to
hit b5 because it will aid is hanging
besides the fact they could take on d7
but yeah rook t1 would be it would be
annoying you know I hope I hope after
rook t1 again people are not considering
to strongly play something like e 5 just
in a long-term that's gonna be very
unpleasant so Rick do you one rook t1
could have been played as an alternative
so what do you want
and I was yeah you wanted to play maybe
Bishop c5 here just an example white
rook t1 might be very dangerous maybe
hear something like b4 and things get
things get pretty out of hand for for
black so there's a few different options
and later on coming to play rook e1 in
the match but they shipped out for this
time the ship g3 and you can still play
rook d1 so there wasn't necessarily big
sense of urgency
and now a very interesting move I didn't
necessarily expect was f5 really trying
to force the issue and open up the G
file yeah
Bishop takes g3 would not be good
shutting down the G file which black
badly wants and now poses a pretty
serious question for for white because
f4 is coming and you really do not want
to now play Bishop d6 or you don't want
to admit that because black in the
benefit of that five which isn't isn't a
bad move at all because it you know
supports efore and control some some
center squares so after F 5 F 4 is
coming no matter what now crime that
goes to rook F F 2 c1
for example rook F 2 D 1 F 4 which is
what Islands idea was Bishop to h4 we
have this move that comes often in this
opening rook a 5 and Y is Rho K 5
annoying well first of all you're not
giving this [ __ ] up and up in positions
you know this this isn't what why it's
not going to give this up because black
has a lot of pressure on g2 oh so the
obvious move after here would be like a
4 but why for so annoying is there's a
rook takes p5 exchange sacrifice a b5
forest if Queen b5 bishop takes that you
trade Queens and you play Bishop at 3
and after rook so rook p5 a b5 position
like 95 and everything is you know
the tactics are working a lot so for
example 95 rook G to King f1 is forced
work takes h2 this simply rotates hu
threatening work h1 checkmate Knight f3
rook h1 check
I mean why it's just not surviving it
there's just no way they like trade
things off or or stop the bishops
there's just a long term thing so yeah
this would this would just be very very
bad for for white so there's some nice
tactics starting to emerge in this
position and our k5 is an example if you
were to move the bishop away the same
tactic would happen even better so I
mean like let's say let's say 95 yeah
and something like this probably here
you can do they should takes g2 and and
I've three or f3 right away it's just
bad
it's just very very very bad so after
work F 2 d1 yeah I might've been
something that kramnik saw and was not
thrilled to allow an interesting
possibility here was Knight takes d4 the
idea of playing with d1 next so no Queen
takes d4 you don't want to be doing this
it takes King takes rook over
Knight takes d4 interesting possibility
f4 and I don't know how deep these guys
were prepared by the move after move
like f4 things things it's really hard
to hit to figure out what's going on
here you have to take Queen takes King
f8
so one example might be here Queen a5
check well it'd be nice if after like
let's say Bishop d7 white could take
back with the F pawn and have a check
discovered check it's not working here
and black would probably be waiting with
with some black would probably be
winning here very very shortly well I
just checked me to myself actually but
that's exactly it
but yeah there's some counter play I
think white would probably try to go for
a draw then Queen f5 check King g7 yeah
it's it's it's a mess it's a bit of a
mess but there probably is a perpetual
here so f5 rook F 2 C 1 F 4 bishop h4
and now quite a nice move here I like
this move a lot Bishop to e7 the bishop
has done its job on d6 doesn't really
have more of a future there and goes to
back to e7 trading that bishop ball I
like that and bringing the King towards
the the center
the same variation that I was talking
about before okay five maybe a four rook
takes P five I think what was annoying
about this variation
was after Queen b5 they're capable of
all if you take care of this is almost
checkmate Queen has to go back but if
you trade Queens I think it's the same
thing I think it's the same thing that
you can't take on f3 because rook c8 is
checkmate so that's why it doesn't work
the bishop when you seven is you know
there's some checkmate checkmate
patterns there so there should be seven
it's pretty precise chronic plays a four
because he doesn't want to improve
blacks position [ __ ] after Bishop d7
Kingston black once the King on g7 now
after a four hundred Bishop h4 Knight
age four Qing Yi seven and some material
is still even and it's you know still
still totally unclear
I like blacks position for sure but you
have to maintain that sort of initiative
here pawns on the dark squares f4 and d4
and a light squared bishop it looks it
looks well coordinated and now what is
black threatening next move rook takes
g2 Knight takes G - yeah that's an
important point so if it was black to
move here I'll just demonstrate that
rook G to 92 no not f3
so that rook rook to g8
all right look treated what if f3 what
was the plan here pawn up Queen f2
maybe it is f3 so it's an idea but it's
not it's not you know it is kind of
position specific whether it works or
not but it's definitely something both
of the players are are considering here
rook a3 was chosen which is a nice
multi-purpose move you know it can help
on the kingside can help in the center
okay to see it the tactics aren't
working the rook isn't doing too much on
it but white black concentrated because
I don't think really sees a better
square than then trading it I mean you'd
maybe be tempted to double rooks on the
G file here and put some pressure on g2
but it looks it looks it looks a little
risky
I mean just to put everything everything
on that maybe I can just react with f3
you don't really want if you if you if
you don't contest the C file black you
always have to be worried about white
playing work c7 a certain point of the
Queen isn't protecting c7 so it's
interesting because again though if this
was just a pure pawn and game then you
want to be favoring the two outside pass
pawn so ah to what extent are you are
you willing to drag pieces as black it's
definitely a question here that you have
to constantly be thinking about because
yeah I mean I think blacks a lot of
blacks kind of a play is based on you
know counter-attacking and and white
can't really get a nice setup going on
they have to deal with g2 all the time
so black concedes rotated to see it now
that the rock a five tactics don't work
crime that goes for this is like less
pressure on G to one way or another and
I was pretty I was always surprised by
this I Center pounds are really nice but
I just didn't really see a good
situation where black could utilize that
at the same time
White's Knight is on H for Rick is on
III why it's not perfectly coordinated
either and that Bishop on b5 might start
looking a bit superficial soon if it
doesn't it just stays there and it
doesn't take on d7 or or do too much
then it might it might end up being
missed out and some some sequences I was
doing you know electro yesterday I'm
kind of keeping pieces on the board and
or a couple days ago and after work c8
definitely a rook c1 could be something
to be considered
look do you want to sad sorry Brooke c1
to do one I don't think White's forced
to take on c8 and this this is good this
is good
I don't think black can use the C file
to do anything special so I think work
d1 would have been very playable
alternative here
maybe double up yeah maybe double up on
d3 yeah right rook the rook t1 might be
might have been a better try instead
rook c8 bishop CA and rook a1
oh sorry rook takes was played yeah my
bad
rook takes e8 and wreck a 1 so covering
the back rink and now a nice move by
Anand which he must have seen before
going into all this
oh yeah I just want to mention Knight a5
check is never really working black just
plays like King f6 so then why it
doesn't have a follow-up check so after
rook c8 rook a 1 I really like Queen c5
you know the Queen this is the fact you
know why I can't get before going it it
takes control of the C file and it also
has options to you know swing over to
the Kings side it's a very versatile
square
maybe Queen d5 as well right and lining
lining the Queen and Bishop out but
Queen C 5 in C 5 seems like a nice
smooth improving the the position I'm
not sure blacks gonna play Queen c2 but
Lee just leaves White has to anticipate
a lot of different Queen moves and
that's not easy to to deal with chronic
played Queen g4 here which mm not not
entirely sure
move up Queen d2 maybe trying to hit f4
and play b4 might have been preferable
Queen g5 here Queen takes d4 and D
something probably Queen d6 let's say
rook 81 this might have put black under
a little bit of pressure the problem is
the problem is is the tactics are quite
often in blacks favor after 95 because
you're not playing a 5 you go Queen d4
okay that doesn't work right check
that's not too hard to see after Bishop
a6
but where how do you free up space for
your king does it move like h3 really
desirable like it's it also has some
drawbacks
whether that be f3 here it's it's it's
not a long-term real safe square that's
I mean okay I'm not sure about I'm not
sure of black and play f3 here because
maybe Queen g5 check but h3 just HTM you
accentuates I move like work she it I
sound like I was thinking maybe like you
know Queen D for some sort of
Knight takes Knight f3 check I wanted to
do net net net XG - uh it's yeah
kramnik play queen g4 Queenie 525
protecting the pawns and centralizing
that Queen it can defend it can block
checked with f6 all the basics is
putting the Queen on the dark squares
Bishop allied squared is kind of
yes Knight f6 and rook g8 yeah right now
it's on you know what blacks rook looks
a little better than whites rook and
after night she f6 or g8 looks like
it'll be a lot better I mean as white I
think you you don't mind getting the
Queen's off in this position but once
again I not easy to see how white can
get the Queen's off it's like one of
those position looks like if tactics are
favoring black a pure endgame might
favor white but that's that's a really
hard and game to to get until then the
tactics look like they're favoring Black
Knight f3 Queen f6 well you do want to
get the night away from each for the
nano d7 is better than eight on each for
so brings the okay brings the knight
back into the game I think the only
losing move here might be a move like
Bishop f3 giving up the bishop letting
the a pawn run that's something the
bishop on b7 is really such an important
piece for black so I just want to make
sure nobody is giving that up clean up 6
what's wrong with Queen g5 here because
I was saying white wants to get the
Queen's off the board this is even for
example Queen g5 Bishop f3 Queen takes
Knight takes pawn things yeah you
doubled F pawns but I don't think
White's too concerned by that too passed
pawns should run should be just you have
a point Arjun
I'm Richie 8 yep
you know H 4 H 6 no matter what rook
takes g2 is coming
if Bishop d7 you just play the cool
Ritchie 5 maybe defend the you know it's
going to end game you got the to pass
pawns but just the whites a little too
slow in achieving that right it's just
black black will be up too much so a 4
is still a long way from me so graumlich
can't rush the position yet
please rook to e1 what's interesting is
I believe Kramnik was playing for a win
slower so the fighting I mean he was
down you know one game and this was in
the middle of the match Bishop takes d7
King G seven maybe Knight takes d4 yeah
you don't take a good I would find it I
think black is okay because you have so
much counter play but and he's down upon
those pawns will be hard to push on the
Queen side but that's a King g7 we're
getting out of the way let's look to you
1c for black black is black is getting a
lot of counter play I'm not sure if
chromatic like what is but like if he
was playing for when you wouldn't want
to do this because it feels like black
should should be able to find ways to
hold pretty easily but I don't think
white is in I don't think white is in a
lot of danger when the pawns when blacks
pawns are all on the Kings side when you
have a bishop you wanna have pawns on
both sides of ward stretch out but you
know like it's it's not it's not the
worst endgame to enter here so well you
have a bishop you want pawns on both
sides award your pawns as well so you
can stretch out the position the bishop
can kind of like control it can control
two sides of the board and I can't
really do that so that's why bishops or
favorite and open positions and usually
open positions will have activity all
over the place so yeah yeah
now's a possibility play rook to you one
maybe that's stopping 95 because we look
at a position where 95 gets achieved I
don't know say h4
well how would we treat this as black
well I'm curious how that position is
looking like how desirable it is to go
for this once again you can't rush it as
white rook c5 and you pick off g5 and
eight fives not possible yet don't want
to rush it but this position is it is
this better for black better for white
what is the evaluation it's pretty
pretty hard to tell it must be hard for
the players to figure figure it out for
sure I think black has to be happy to
get a lot of activity but I'm not sure
black can claim too much
yeah you wouldn't to put your pawns on
light squares that would be on the same
color of your Bishop and should be a
little bit loose but just a position
like this as long as I can break down
pretty soon as long as white cannot push
the Queen side majority blocks probably
better because black like has that
Center presence and can use their own
pawns so you know as long as the Queen's
can't be traded and we just have this
position with with Queens and bishops
and rooks on the board then black should
have some fun tactics available why it
needs to try to get into a position
where you can slowly try to get progress
on the Queen side because otherwise I
think dynamically the position is
favorable to block and he has more
pieces in the middle of the board and
towards the Kings and plays rook c5 here
you really wants ninety five because you
have other reasonable moves work c2
maybe before
now move like rooks III threatening
Bishop takes out three little annoying
for sure I mean for example let's say
Bishop d7 King be seven
I think the tactics are just favouring
block here despite those two paths pawns
on the Queen side you can't play 95
because the Queen takes e5 let's say
play H it's three it's still a long way
to go before those pawns
yeah those pawns uh still have a ways to
go I don't I don't even think King King
e7 necessary but but I'm not one for
rook c5 and said
looks like he wants 95 he's not getting
rooked g5 I think 95 and it has to be 95
no I mean I guess objectively the
position is still fairly balanced if
they play accurately and and and if he
gets 95 everything gets traded off like
let's just say h3 95 but just because we
need to know if this is good because
he's going for a 95 well I think black
is okay but it shouldn't be more than
that with upon on weak pawn on f4 and
just Queens and bishops
but before come was like okay I don't
mind going into into this position just
an example let's say 95 which wasn't
played yeah I don't think don't think I
meant would be too thrilled to have a
position like this so it's unclear if
you played rook c5 just as a debate 95
and provoked before or he's actually
gonna do it cuz I don't think is gonna
do it like here this should be good for
white like even a position like Queen
check well I was looking at something
like this and clean up for and the
outside pass pawn is still an asset and
these type of positions probably
something really sharp would be
happening in this type of race gets a
little it gets pretty pretty pretty
messy might be in the best interest in
some variation like this to to just make
a draw up a point also I mean this
position I I can you know I'm sure I'm
making analysis mistakes cuz this
engines will get out there's all just
this is just pure tactics the last 20
moves the whole position is just very
very tactical so you know the players
themselves are probably you know looking
for ways to make it easier to understand
because otherwise every single moves
got to watch out for certain things it
gets pretty tired tired after before it
also rooks III which wasn't available
beforehand which is why I'm not sure it
works see if I really want to play 95
hours kind of trying to provoke before
to get this c3 square because now Bishop
takes f3 95 is a threat the Queen's are
on the board there you can give up a
bishop if the Queen's are on the board
alright I this 95 here game over and I
takes f3
but it's Queens are staying on crime
they committed a blunder here and it
takes d4 it takes d4 it is it is a
annoying position to deal with but once
again I think you're white you got to be
looking towards Bishop f3 sorry but
dividing Bishop takes d7 King takes d7
and playing this sort of position yep
move it may be moving the night
somewhere we've looked at this position
before I think black is totally fine but
white white also a black is preferable
actually I mean I think chronic looked
at it blocks I think a little bit better
here but I don't think it's it's it's
it's enough to push the position too
much because even a position like here
I'm not too concerned about Bishop takes
f3 it messes up blocks massive white
structure but with only a queen in a
rock I don't think that's gonna be a big
problem yeah yeah but Knight takes d4
plate oh not in this position but yeah
Knight takes d4 also couldn't play 92
once again trying to you know plan maybe
94 at some point just or just we'll just
avoid Bishop takes up through like 95
I think that for you know queen Queen e2
still not clear still not clear that
Knight takes d4 the idea of Knight takes
d4 obvious a queen takes d4 is rook to
e1 what to do is black here the Queen
Toxie for happens
well if Queen doesn't take Black is in
big problem like big trouble here down
upon that was an important pawn there's
no more like rook g2 threats Bishop f3
why it's advance to be to pawn to b4
everything else I mean I move like 95
years Queenie too quickly what happens
after Queen takes d4 and rook yeah
Queen takes d4 rook t1 yeah
Queen texty for rook to e1 you haven't
Knight f6 that's the issue of the
position so native six
Queen moves away well the Queen can't
move away then you're just down a piece
so Knight f6 no not an 85 does not do
the same thing the right idea but you do
give up a check
so it's Knight f6 okay you can't move
the Queen now because then black just
moves their Queen away so rook takes d4
Knight takes d4 d7 check
no there's no back rank King f6 rook
takes d7 and now yeah exactly
rook c1 check bishop f1 and if black
doesn't have a tactic here you know a 5
a 6 a 7 but 93 a nice nice pattern it's
the first time I had seen it when the
game was played you can take so I think
that's what happened it took on f3 I
took on e3 in this position but he took
first yeah yeah and there's no way to
stop eetu or the back rank but for the
most part like to me I'm okay I mean
obviously like Chazz is like they get
into a tactical position and cronic made
some blunders but the position always
had a lot of tension so at a certain
point it kind of just just cracked I
think the position was pretty balanced
for most of it and it looks like it
looks like rook c5 turned out to be
quite successful to get rook c3 I mean
it definitely led to a blunder right
right away but yeah I'm not sure how
concerned you have to be about 95 is
white but I I liked I liked the idea of
rook c8 it turned out you know turned
out turned out pretty pretty good but it
is it is not too easy to change gears
you know blacks compensation was here on
the G file for example and some tactical
threats and then after Rick a threes
like evaluates position I don't see a
way to to continue that or it's not
worth it to commit all all my time to
that so I'm gonna play rook rook c8 and
I do believe I
work d1 should should have been played
just to keep the tension in the center
it probably probably my type of
preference there but otherwise just a
very sharp game and this was like you
know Anand is quite he's made a career
out of playing playing these sort of
sharp positions very very well so and
he's doing in the candidates right now
so will yourself we shall see what
happens